I also think that it's a question of
degree like um we have two daughters and
I
constantly try to you know do what I can
uh to have them understand that you make
whatever choices you want to make with
uh your life uh romantically you know
it's I'm never in a great rush to talk
about it and I know that there's
something sexist about that because I'll
talk to my son about it I'm not so crazy
about talking to my daughter
but whatever I I I'm flawed and I say
just make sure you're making choices for
you that if you want to wear that you
wear it but don't wear it because you
think that that's what some guy expects
of you and I think it's really important
for um any and anybody is that you're
living your own truth as you say you
know you use the word uh you know truth
about what you're saying and why you
believe there's value to it and that's
what I say you you know you want to date
this guy that's fine but not because you
feel that he is some kind of measure of
your own worth I think that's important
for women to not be defined by who they
are with and I think that's important
for men to not be defined um by who they
are with I just wish there was more
space to it and I don't see it as
weakness or Towing the line uh I think
the reason that my wife is uh still with
me is because she knows I'm
desperate uh to get better and I am I
have a sense of desperation about
self-improvement
um one of the upsides of [__] up a
lot isn't that interesting huh and the
second part is I find humor in a lot of
things in life and that works for her
that we laugh a lot and we laugh a lot
even when we should be crying and I
think there's something to that so I
think that's the match now I look at
those things as a function of my
strength you know I I've I know what
it's like to get hit I know what it's
like to get hit with a bare fist I know
what it's like to get hit with a stick
and I know what it's like to get hit uh
with an insult and a judgment that is
much more painful than any beating I've
ever taken and I've had at least 100
stitches put in my head and my neck so I
think that's a function of my strength
and to other
men very often they'll say to me
especially if they're Alpha type guys
man you got a lot of beta in you um you
know you got a lot of you know oh how
you feel and that this is hard and
different kind I see that all as parts
of strength you you know that vulner
vulnerability could be strength me
telling you that I have a problem is
strength it's a big problem with mental
health with men right very few of your
buddies may call you up I don't know
your friend Circle but to be like holy
cow I could barely get up today and it's
not because I was deadlifting uh 500
pounds yesterday it's because I I don't
know I think I got like a wave of
depression coming on or something we
don't talk like that I just wish we did
you know there's so many things
unpacking there like ways of depression
and um you know how your wife looks at
you and the concept of you being
beta
um you know I think the guys in my um
inside Circle because again you know I
said like I didn't know who Chris was
you know and they summed you up as your
typical New York liberal right and I'm
like okay I don't know what that is
really I mean I know what a liberal is
and I've been in New York so I'm not
really sure what this what this guy is
because you know when you messag me you
know you said hey you I'd like to have a
conversation with you and I wasn't sure
who you were you know so you know we
kind of went back and forth and I
thought okay you know this guy seems all
right you let's have a conversation cuz
I'm always suspicious of people when
they ask me you know I want to have a
conversation about what you talk and
they're from the media right they're
usually disingenuous and it's too uh
frame you um that's not my thing yeah no
I'm no New York liberal either okay um
so I see as a guy that that's that's
physically strong and uh important
dominant and you know like as a leader
in that regard in sense and you said
something very very interesting you know
you said that you're on this constant
pursuit of self-improvement const and if
you go through my videos and my content
I mentioned on my book in a few places
too you know I always tell guys you
can't relax as a man right you cannot
relax in life as a man you can't get
married you know take your nuptuals put
your feet up and watch sports and sit
there all day and end up with Cheeto
dust on your shirt not doing anything
with your life outside of work women
expect you to do something with your
life with your spare time like you have
to chase Excellence as a man it's funny
I was talking to this baseball player
he's an MLB baseball player a couple
weeks ago he reached out to me said I
like your [__] I want to you know get
together and have a conversation so I
did and you know he was telling me you
know he's got three rings you know he
was telling me that he was sitting on
his couch one day and his wife said to
him what are you doing why are you just
sitting there this is a man whose world
class in his realm of life has retired
and has decided to put his feet up and
take a nap and he said I'm taking a nap
everything you see here I paid for you
see and I think it's okay I think it's
absolutely okay for guys to be a little
bit arrogant like that and you know set
some frame and some boundaries in the
relationship and I think women want to
test those to see that they're looking
at a guy that is their best option that
is the best that they can do because
that's how they look at you you know
they see you as more than just a husband
right you know they see you as more than
just that so sure are you going to get
criticisms of being called a beta sure
people will call you every name under
the sun and you're used to it just like
I am it's like water off a duck's back
at some point because you know who you
are and that level of Competency and
structure that you have in your mind and
the way you hold yourself out is
understood by people that get it and
especially the ones that you want to get
it like I said earlier you know when I
looked you up I didn't know who you were
and I said okay you know who was this
guy Chris and and the first thing that
came to mind is I'd have a beer with
that guy he looks like the kind of guy
that I could sit down with right so we
we do judge people you know and one of
the things that you kind of eluded to
during our conversation here is you know
should we be judging people as a right
you know you know can we get past those
things and just sort of like let people
be as they want to be sort of thing and
I think there's certain areas in life
like I'm a bit of a Libertarian like
just do your thing just don't hurt
anybody right like you know I think it's
okay you know for stuff like that but we
do judge people and it's and it's why we
have to take ownership and do the work
on ourselves as men men and you know go
out there and put a it doesn't matter
how big of it is but you have to go out
there and put a little dent in the
universe whether it's big or small I
think Steve Jobs said this you know
about his Apple business but like you
have to go out there and you have to put
a little bit of a dent in the universe
and do something of some significance so
women appreciate that I think you're
absolutely right and uh I think
that I think one of the greatest values
I see in what you're doing is that uh
message of one you rarely have anybody
to blame but yourself and that notion
sorry to sorry to interrupt you but that
notion of taking ownership I think think
is a lost art very very few people today
will take ownership for the results that
they get in their lives and I think that
is something that our grandparents and
great-grandparents had infused in the
fabric of society and culture you know
within us and it it seems like that has
been removed they want you to be a
victim because it's easier to be a
victim because when you're a victim you
have some sort of oppressor and then
that's when culture Society media like
all of these things we'll call it
collectively The Matrix or something
just to placeholder on whatever is we
want but that's that's what is the
disservice you know to society in
general is we have this General victim
mindset oh poor me I've got these
results because of insert you know
whoever hurt them sort of thing and it's
like no that's not the way that it
should work and we should remove the
victim mindset from society not not
Infuse it into it I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of use links to my website my supplement
line books and a bunch of other stuff
have an amazing day peace out